let's check in with Peter King football
night in America NBC Sports does a
terrific job with them over there Peter
let me ask you do you understand what
Matt Negi was talking about after the
game when it came to that particular
situation you know Chris I wrote about
this in my column today and I basically
said look I did not talk to Matt Negi I
don't know in a in anything more than a
speculative way why he did what he did
but I am going to interpret it because
I've covered it for 35 years I think I
know why coaches do certain things okay
when the Chicago Bears were at the 21
yard line and Mitch Mitchell turbit with
43 seconds to go and Mitchell too risky
took a snap and he kneeled down which
actually lost a yard it took him a yard
further away from a field goal so when
he did that what Matt Nagy was saying
and the reason why he dismissed it so
out of hand is that he can't be seen as
having any lack of confidence in his
offense in his running game in his
quarterback so by him basically saying
what are you talking about I I don't I
mean this is unquestioned this is what
you would do which is the silliest thing
I've ever heard in my life and anybody
who's watched football for 15 minutes
knows it's silly that if you have a
chance instead of kicking a 41-yard
field goal to kick a 24 yard field goal
of course you're going to do that why
would you choose to kick a field goal
from a further distance and the fact
that he had one timeout and 43 seconds
to go and chose not to go closer to the
goal line to make the field goal easier
for his field goal kicker to me this is
just me deep down inside he has zero
confidence in Mitchell to risky
playing productive turn over free foot
well that's what I inferred and in Chris
I'll just say one other thing even if
you have no confidence in your offense
there are ways very incredibly low-risk
ways to try to get extra yards
among them you've got one of the shifty
it's running back there is tarik Cohen
who does not have a fumbling problem
figure away to try to get him on the
edge and if he can't get any extra yards
dive into the line and just move on but
I I just think that he doth protest too
much
yeah I agree with you I mean low risk
possibility running straight up the
middle it doesn't send a great message
you're awful or her or too risky Archer
Biscay throwing the ball to the
sidelines you know are making a very
low-risk throw but I think it's just a
sign that he just doesn't trust his
offense right now to do anything
I wondered Peter and I thought the
reporters in Chicago did a good job of
asking him specific questions after the
game I wonder if he believes any of the
things he was saying like throw the ball
why would we could have an interception
run the ball why would we I mean this
guy's been around he's a was a pretty
good coach last year what if he believes
any of this again all I'm you know what
I like Matt Negi
I really do I know him and I think yeah
I think he's in a situation right now
I mean I I see ur eyes it I put it this
way you know let's use the two
quarterbacks who were picked below you
know who were picked after Mitchell to
Biscay in the 2017 Draft
deshaun Watson and Patrick bombs do you
think Bill O'Brien or Andy Reid with 43
seconds and one timeout left would have
kneeled on the ball and chosen the 41
yard field goal I don't think so no I
don't think so at all and so I just
think he is in a tough situation with a
quarterback who is having a crisis of
confidence and he can't trust and I
don't blame that nagy for not trusting
to risky
terr Biscay has been a nightmare and so
now you have to just determine what's
our best chance to win this game this
week and that's why Hey last Monday in
my column I wrote if I were Matt Negi
you know I would I would seriously
consider starting chase Daniel against
the Los Angeles chargers his only job
right now is not the fragile psyche not
managing the fragile psyche of his
quarterback it's doing everything he can
to save his season
they're three and four right now and as
I pointed out this morning imagine just
imagine if it Denver the fairly
controversial decision of putting one
second back on the clock so Eddie Panero
could take a 53-yard field goal to win
imagine if that one second wasn't put on
the clock right now the Chicago Bears
would be 2 and 5 this week headed into a
game at Philadelphia that probably you
look at the two teams now I think the
Bears are likely to lose imagine them
being 2 and 6 and having their season
over basically on Halloween talking to
Peter King NBC sports football morning
in America does a terrific job over
there Peter I'm watching the Browns game
last night and not surprised that they
lose to New England but that's a sloppy
playing team another penalty filled team
I couldn't help but think what if Hugh
Jackson was coaching that team what
would we be saying about Hugh Jackson
that maybe we're not saying right now
about Freddie kitchens good man he'd be
fired and I think the only reason there
is a similar demand is that I think
Freddie kitchens is new he's coached
seven games you're not gonna fire a guy
after seven games but I think Freddie
kitchens is smart enough to know that if
he puts up a 5 and 11 on the results
scoreboard this year there'd be real
question about whether he'd come back in
20 21 or 20 20 rather he's having a very
bad mcadoo type of year honestly and you
know I kind of in his second year not
his first
and I kind of look at the Browns and
before the year
I remember getting absolutely skewered
by Cleveland fans I didn't pick the
Browns to make the playoffs and my point
was that there is a huge difference
between playing 15 games at one o'clock
on a Sunday afternoon and having the
fifth CBS crew do your game every week
and basically nobody paying any
attention to you other than you know the
legions of Browns fans around the
country there's a difference between
that and having three of your first five
games put on primetime one on NBC Sunday
Night Football two of them on Monday
Night Football in the first five weeks
of the season every game that you play
everybody in America is paying attention
there's a big difference everybody said
all what does that mean what do you mean
but what is that no no no it means a lot
how do you handle the white-hot
spotlight and the Cleveland Browns are
not handling it at all and the other
thing they are not disciplined in a
football sense that's coming back to
haunt them right now you know Peter you
look at the AFC and there seems to be a
pretty clear hierarchy with the Patriots
the Chiefs at the top two positions on
the NFC five teams with at least at
least six wins how do you peg the order
who's the best team in the NFC you know
one of the things when I look at the
schedule down the stretch I mean just
look at if you are the San Francisco
49ers right now and you're trying to
look a little bit down the road look at
weeks 12 13 and 14 you play three teams
with a combined 19 and four record you
know you play New Orleans Baltimore and
Green Bay I think it I got the order ROG
you play Green Bay at home and then you
play you play Baltimore in New Orleans
on the road and and that is going to be
you know a real big test for a would be
for any team and now for the 49ers being
seven and oh look the 49ers have been
great
they're darlings right now and they
should be to beat Carolina and put up 51
points on them and basically call off
the dogs it could have been worse that
was an amazing performance by the Niners
but you know in the last however many
weeks of the season I thought yeah in
the last eight weeks of the season they
have Seattle twice the Rams once they
got Green Bay they got New Orleans I
mean they have one heck of a tough
schedule in the last half of this season
we'll see how they do I think they have
the advantage right now but it's all
it's who gets hot down the stretch
that's who's gonna win home-field
advantage in the NFC and Chris I'll say
one other thing can you imagine if
you're having a kind of year that Green
Bay and New Orleans is having Green Bay
New Orleans in San Francisco all of them
can't get home field in the NFC one of
those three teams is going to be playing
on wildcard weekend with no bye so I
mean there is a lot to play for in the
last half of the season at the top of
the NFC a lot of parody in the NFC with
the NFL trade deadline with a tomorrow
coming up yeah been some moves already
yeah you expecting a busy trade deadline
I am you know I've been writing about
this a lot I wrote a lot about it last
week that I think a lot of things have
changed in the NFL ten years ago in the
entire calendar year 2009 there were 39
trades involving players this year so
far as of the Kenyan Drake trade this
morning from Miami to Arizona there have
been 60 trades I think there's going to
be between 65 and 70 by the close of
business on Tuesday and I just think
teams believe now that the draft is not
this incredible Holy Grail if
a hole to fill you know in the middle of
October they're gonna go out and try to
fill it with a player Arizona is really
not playing for anything you know other
than respectability but they say hey
we'll go out and prove our team by
getting a running back and who knows
Kenyan Drake might be a part of this
team for the next two or three years I
get you out here with this watch the
Titans against the Bucs last night
little depressing watching those two
teams in a game that was pretty
high-profile just four years ago if you
had to buy stock in the future of one
quarterback Mariota or Jameis Jameis
Winston who would you take well Mariota
Mariota right now is a penny stock Chris
he's almost certainly not going to
regain his job in Tennessee and will be
on the free agent market after this
season he's probably going to have to
take the Ryan Tannehill route our route
of being of going somewhere as a backup
and hoping at some point he gets another
chance Jameis Winston right now still
has his future in Tampa in his hands if
he plays well the rest of the year in
limits his turnovers I would expect that
he will get a short term contract to
continue in Tampa but that is absolutely
not a sure thing
if he's the turnover machine he has been
in his first four and a half years then
the Bucks will probably look elsewhere
too but as of right now he's the only
one of the two as a chance to stay with
his team
I would think beyond this year Dan Quinn
survived the season
I mean maybe but what does that mean I
you know I think Arthur Blank just wants
to make it go away he wants to wave a
magic wand and make the pain go away but
I keep hearing that Arthur Blank might
be in the mood to blow it all up the
entire organization there in salary cap
he'll next year and they're gonna have a
bad team so I can't tell you what's
going to happen whether he'll survive
the year but whether he does or not he's
gonna make a coaching change at the end
of this year at the very latest what do
you think that means for Matt Ryan
that's a good question you know if I
were met
and I would love it to be blown up Matt
Ryan's going to be a productive player
no matter who the coach is he needs
somebody to come in and take these
defensive parts these disparate
defensive parts and parts and and make
it into a good cohesive team they get a
couple of excellent players led by Grady
Jared on defense and their defense
thinks they're gonna have to do it with
low-cost players in undrafted
and-and-and real free agency because
they don't they're not going to have any
money to spend in free agency so I think
it just means that Matt Ryan stays and
Matt Ryan becomes the cornerstone he and
Julio Jones of the rebuild always great
to talk to you Peter I appreciate the
time all the best Chris take care all
right it's Peter King football morning
in America NBC Sports joining us here on
the Dan Patrick show if you missed any
of our celebrity interviews this week
from the mercedes-amg man cave just got
to dant the Dan Patrick app we could
watch and list from inside the
mercedes-amg man cave mercedes-amg
driving performance for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]